in this capsule we will see how to comment
what we can represent an image in
a computer as part of a system
computer vision
gold we distinguish two bodies the first
it's the one of images in levels of
gray so black and white
so in this case also an image like
this one here we go there represented as
a two-dimensional array so having
two indices' the index of the row and
column index for pixels
in the picture and at each element of
table in fact we see there associates a
8-bit positive integer that actually goes
given information on the intensity of
pixel so at 0 it will match a
pixel that is in black then to more
the error is high plus the pixel goes
get closer to white so we see by
example at 191 on the pixel that is
almost white so pixels totally
saturated so totally white can have
a value in this case also because we
had 8 bits of 255 one sees for
intermediate values ​​to the data of the
different gurit levels and so I
recalls that the first clue in this
case vote is the row and the
second index will match the
column so this is one of the ways to
represent the images so
important by the computer this is a
way of representing it that is often
actually used in systems of
computer vision
but in sound and images that are not
in black and white but which are rather in
colors in this case also make it see
table in three dimensions or what we
going to have is that each pixel rather
than to be described by a single integer
8-bit positive
we will describe by three positive integer
which will correspond to three channels their
canoe red cannon towards and during the
red channel canada and the blue channel
so in this case we go components
makes each color in intensity for
the intensity of the red channel of the canal
green and blue channel so both
first clues are always going
corresponds to the position
and then the last clue you
correspond for the first element to
red duck the second the green the
third blue and there are others
ways to break down a color at 1.3 to
three channels a media what if the one that
we will consider who is perhaps the
most popular is the one with
rgb channels so already with this
representation there finally we could
develop vision systems by
computer for example that we could
to do is we could take a
picture x which corresponds to our table
of pixels we could convert it into a
vector little hic what in what if
match the image but we would put
the pixels into one in a table
of a single dimension so in
converting two dimensions into one
only pair by ranking the pixels in
some to the pope for example in a
order by row and one could
give this picture there is a collection
of picture to be hardened learning for
try to learn something to
from this raw representation of
images against it is so there is
a lot of research work going on
are doing from this representation
we are going to say gross of the image then
try to solve different age of
computer vision
these while some problems
except representation there a first
it's a representation that
is heavy in terms of memory so on
the 1024 by 1024 pixels which is more
in fact only in the images demonstrated
previously we had very little crisis
and we had images of 28 by 28 and
in black and white then 32 by 32 years in
colors but typically we can
easily have pictures a lot
bigger reason of 1024 1024 and if
we have 8 bits per pixel for the level
gray it gives about
1 but gbagbo is an experienced man
and then if we had 24 24 bits instead
yes so 3 x 8 bits for all three
channels and we end up with rather
three guys by picture
so that's a first problem
potential that this representation
then the second son is that well
often it contains a lot more
information that what we need
for an application of his wishes
detect the cars in the pictures the
color is not particularly useful
in fact it's mostly the form of
the object that will determine if a car
or not and if we detect an object in
general in fact all that is there it's
we or if we want the background
releasing the scene in which
the object may be ignored for
identify the identity of the object one
try to detect then what can
to do is we will see you some
operations that we will say good level
so applied directly to the images
gross who are going to be relatively
simple but that we will be able to
pretreatments on the images that are going
extract the information can be more
relevant
so he's going to highlight
the most interesting information for
solve different vision problems
by computer